Leoben Leoben fleiger
mm-hmm stacking shelves is a thankless
task but these two young Greek women are
grateful to be doing it in Berlin even
though their university graduates
they've accepted they have to start
right at the bottom in their new home
with an apprenticeship in retail sales I
studied economics in Greece but sadly I
can't find a job there really sadly
there are so many people like us there
who have no job 20 to 35 years old and
unemployed left with nothing there new
German employer is doing well out of
that and he's thrilled with his new
staff then we'll give you to increase
your highly motivated they have fun and
enjoy things they've got great charisma
and that's very important for us large
German companies desperate for qualified
personnel like Siemens are also striking
gold in Greece Tamia Nima Munna is one
of many technicians who see better
professional prospects in Germany than
back home I'm sorry thinking of doing
related to my studies I mean I've said
the electorate in computer engineering
so I have many options but what does
that mean for Greece's economic
prospects professor Nikolas a post-op
Willis came to Germany in the 1960s to
study economics
he says the wave of young people
currently turning their backs on Greece
will make things there even worse it's a
catastrophe those youngsters are needed
and it affects the economy
you can't modernize an economy with old
people Maria and her friend are both
happy living and working in Berlin but
they still don't know yet whether or not
they want to stay for good or if they
might return back home one day after all
my family for instance they used to say
to me come back if it's no good for you
if it gets you down then come back but
now they say you're better off where you
are stay there since the crisis first
erupted in 2010 over 200,000 Greeks have
left the country the young and the best
educated as always the first to go